schleuser wahnsinn an der
grenzkontrollstelle weißer berg zwischen
deutschland und österreich 11 personen
hat die polizei in diesem vw golf
vorgefunden alles afghanische
staatsangehörige
ein 20-jähriger wollte sie illegal nach
deutschland einschleusen
die parteien haben sich für 95 sitzer
gefragt wo weitere personen fanden die
beamten im kofferraum angeklagt
frank hat sich dabei um
erwachsene
einen jugendlichen und
drei kinder wurden alle nach österreich
bürger schon skurril
der fahndungserfolg aus rheinbach vor
allem lebensgefährlich gegen den
ebenfalls afghanischen fahrer wird nun
wegen einschleusens von ausländern
ermittelt er selbst hatte einen
deutschen führerschein uns eine
vorläufige aufenthaltsgenehmigung seine
fahrgäste besaßen eine samt keine
ausweispapiere
allein am vergangenen wochenende hat die
bundespolizei freilassing mit
unterstützung der
bundesbereitschaftspolizei 7
schleusungen gestoppt und dabei
insgesamt 66 unerlaubt eingereiste
vorläufig festgenommen
außerdem haben die beamten 13 uhr kunden
die lücke erkannt und acht offene
haftbefehle vollstreckt mehr nachrichten
und breaking news nur bei bate schau
dich hier das nächste video an und
vergiss nicht zu abonnieren